Ist es endlich soweit ist dass jetzt tatsächlich der endgültige beweis für außerirdisches leben nachdem wir schon so lange suchen wenn
Ja wäre dass tatsächlich die wohl größte entdeckung der mensch ein konkret geht es um eine sehr mysteriöse probe die an der internationalen
raumstation iss
gefunden wurde ein russischer kosmonaut
Ist sich ganz sicher dass diese bakterien aus dem weltraum kommen um welche probe sich genau handelt und ob sie tatsächlich die suche nach
Außerirdischem leben mit einem großen erfolg zu ende bringt jetzt den krieg zum science fiction herzlich willkommen
Diese nachricht ist einfach nur geil
zitat beim entnehmen von abstrichen sind bakterien gefunden worden die während des starts des
moduls noch nicht dort gewesen sind das hat der russische kosmonaut antennen ablauf der staatlichen nachrichtenagentur
Tass ende oktober berichtet seine vermutung die bakterien seien aus dem weltraum richtung iss geflogen und hätten sich dort niedergelassen
gefunden wurde diese probe nach starb lehrers angaben bei einem
weltraumspaziergang an der außenseite der station
Dies liegt wohl schon länger zurück doch erst jetzt fanden sich in den laboren auf der erde wohl die hinweise auf diesen mysteriösen
spuren bei den untersuchungen kamen demnach heraus dass sich darin bakterien befinden
Die eben beim start des moduls noch nicht vorhanden waren so starb lehrer
Das bedeutet sie sind aus dem weltraum gekommen und haben sich an der äußeren oberfläche niedergelassen sie werden bis jetzt
untersucht und es scheint dass sie keine gefahr darstellen doch die analyse der proben ist noch längst nicht abgeschlossen und das heißt tatsächlich
Alles ist möglich doch, am wichtigsten ist jetzt vor allem eine sache
auszuschließen dass die bakterien von der erde stammen denn welche hinweise konkret auf
außerirdisches leben schließen lassen darauf geht der kosmonaut in dem kurzen bericht der nachrichtenagentur tass nicht ein laut der russischen agentur meldung
vermuten die beteiligten kosmonauten jedenfalls dass die mysteriösen bakterien- wohl drei jahre lang
Im weltraum zu gebracht haben müssen das heißt also konkret in einem luftleeren raum mit sagenhaften temperaturschwankungen die von
-150 bis plus 150 grad celsius reichen dennoch wäre eine irdische
kontamination auch eben sehr gut denkbar denn wir haben ja schon öfter darüber berichtet mikroorganismen sind sehr viel robuster
Als man vielleicht denken mag selbst die extremsten bedingungen egal ob auf der erde oder im weltraum scheinen vielen bakterien
Nichts auszumachen bärtierchen zum beispiel sind so gut wie unzerstörbar sie können unter extrem
lebensfeindlichen bedingungen überleben
Realistisch gesehen heißt das wohl dass die mysteriöse bakterien probe mikroben aus der erdatmosphäre
Enthält aber und das ist das spannende wenn bagdad eben von der erde unter diesen bedingungen dort
existieren können dann können auch bakterien von anderen planeten so durch den weltraum reisen und das leben, im universum von einem zum nächsten
sternensystem tragen
Weltraum staub bewegt sich sehr schnell und so ist es nicht unrealistisch dass mikroben aus anderen
Sternensystem mit ihm reisen manche acto biologen und biologin gehen davon aus dass
Genau durch diesen prozess auch das leben auf der erde entstanden es ist aber eben ursprünglich ganz anders
Wo aus der galaxie stammt von der nasa jedenfalls gibt es bisher noch, keine offizielle stellungnahme
Fest steht jedoch dass sich die suche nach außerirdischem leben immer weiter zuspitze den nächsten 20 jahren so schätzt die nasa
Werden wir außerirdisches leben finden wenn er kein video zu diesem thema also wenn er sich verpassen wollte und auch
Zu allen anderen themen dann wird mir hier ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
Genau auf die glocke nur dann verpasst er kein video hier geht es weiter mit dafür draufklicken
Aliens können wir sie leichter finden dafür gibt es nämlich eine menge gründe also ansonsten bis dahin
bleibt dann